[Musique]
l'élan courtois nicolas mon plots 30 ans
pratique le badminton depuis ces dix ans
qui sont six o'clock des volontaires en
cours depuis 2012 il a décidé de
participer ce samedi 4 mars à la 16e
édition du tournoi du club au palais des
sports en présence de 350 autres joueurs
venus principalement d'île de france
je recherche plutôt de m'amuser je fais
pas et de tournois pour finalement les
gagner mais vraiment passé une bonne
ambiance
alors avec avec le club ce soit ici ou
même dans les autres tournois c'est
vraiment de s'amuser
voilà ces tournois de milieu de saison
on arrive au mois de mars
il nous reste quatre mois à faire au
niveau compétition l'arrière jusqu'au
mois de juin aujourd'hui nicolas s'est
inscrit en double la forme du tournoi
le sportif s'est associé à axel a dit un
autre joueur du club âgé de 34 ans leur
objectif remporter la victoire dans leur
catégorie r4 on a une relation plutôt
complémentaires sachant que nikolay il
tape il tape très fort et moi je suis
plus un joueur qui est qu'ils posent et
qui sait servir
premier match et première victoire de la
journée pour les deux élans courtois le
score est sans appel 21 12 et 21 ans
dans le deuxième set
trion une contraction au début de match
mais s'est vite ça s'est vite dissipé
voilà on a pu mettre notre jeu en place
on est on est on est prêt pour le
deuxième match de poule le parcours de
ce duo s'est finalement arrêté en demi
finale dans la catégorie r4 ils
reviendront sans aucun doute l'année
prochaine en mars 2018 pour tenter
d'accrocher cette fois ci la victoire